Morzine gegen Michael Kretschmer
radikale Gegner der Corona Maßnahmen
sollen in einer Chat Gruppe geplant
haben den sächsischen
Ministerpräsidenten zu töten
Landeskriminalamt Sachsen durchsuchte
seit den frühen Morgenstunden in Dresden
mehrere Gebäude Journalisten von ZDF
frontal berichteten als erste über die
Pläne wären mal was das
Landeskriminalamt
Sachsen dazu gesagt hat
SLK ist heute im Einsatz im Zusammenhang
mit der Berichterstattung von frontal wo
es mittlerweile ein Ermittlungsverfahren
gibt wegen einer schweren
staatsgefährdenden Straftat wir befinden
uns hier an ein Objekt wo einer der
Tatverdächtigen
dieses Verfahrens momentan und
durchsucht wird sind seit den frühen
Morgenstunden hier und an weiteren
Objekten im Einsatz
die gibt es auf allen Seiten der
Gesellschaft als Ergebnis dieser
Polarisierung und
es gibt natürlich bei diesen Protesten
auch immer einen Randbereich der
natürlich dann auch zur Gewalt Nike das
ist eine natürliche Entwicklung wir
haben radikale
sage ich mal Corona Gegner bisschen
Ferse Maßnahmen Gegner auch Leugner zum
Teil die 100 000 Anhänger haben in
Telegramm Gruppen oder in anderen Medien
also dass da eine gewisse Resonanz
natürlich entsteht das ist auch
verständlich wie kann man dagegen
vorgehen insbesondere telegram dieser
Nachrichtendienste ja vergleichbar ist
mit Whatsapp aber eben radikal
jedenfalls radikalen Kräften sein Platz
bietet weil er in Dubai ansässig ist ist
es schwer dann Handhabe zu haben ja ich
glaube das ist ein Fehler ist sich auf
bestimmte Marken von Messenger Diensten
zu fixieren dann wenn die jetzt gegen
telegram vorgegangen wird dann wird es
migriert zur anderen Diensten also das
Problem sind nicht die seine Verdienste
wir dürfen nicht vergessen das Telegramm
z.b. auch oppositionellen Kräften in
Weißrussland natürlich eine Plattform
bietet also der Messenger Dienst an sich
ist jetzt nicht unbedingt das Problem
das Problem sind die Inhalte die
transportiert werden und die werden so
oder so transportiert das wird immer
Kanäle geben es wenn immer Kanäle
gesucht das heißen Vorgehen gegen eine
bestimmte Marke wird nicht zum Erfolg
führen man muss hier breiter ansetzen
man muss sie lernen von der
Radikalisierung
Forschungen und deradikalisierung
Bestrebung die man z.b. beim
Dschihadismus
angewandt hat und wo man Erfahrung
gemacht hat muss also prüfen ob man da
z.b. eben Aussteigerprogramm befindet
und letztlich geht es um um Aufklärung
um Umbildung letztlich auch und
natürlich sind auch
gesamtgesellschaftliche
Notwendigkeiten daher wäre heute morgen
Olaf Scholze lange gehört der unter
anderem auch zu diesem Thema Hase im
Internet Hass im Netz Stellung genommen
hat Sandra Berndt gehört und er hat
gesagt da da werden wir harte Kanten
Galgen ja klar das ist auch wichtig dass
man gegen Extremisten und es ist ja auch
heute morgen passiert dass man da
natürlich entsprechend auch harte
polizeiliche Maßnahmen zeigt das ist
auch ein Symbol gewesen dass man hier
auch mit dem sek eben an gerückt ist
dauert und ganz klar in einem frühen
Bereich niederschwellig gleich diese
Planungen dies offensichtlich gegeben
hat die unterbunden hat um eben auch
möglichen anderen Gruppierungen und
Nachahmern die hier vielleicht ähnliches
Plan aufzuzeigen dass ich ihr die dass
sie konsequent durch die Behörden
durchgebrochen was wurde eigentlich
überhaupt geschrieben es geht um diese
brisanten Aussagen aus der radikale
Gruppe Dresden offline Vernetzung die
nach eigenen Angaben scharfe Waffen und
Armbrüste besitzen will und das wurde
geschrieben das haben wir beim offline
treffen gesagt dass wir dann hier den
Ministerpräsidenten absägen man müsste
eigentlich bei dem Typen einmarschieren
den Typen daraus ziehen irgendwo absägen
und dann den nächsten und Sofa
das ist harter Tobak aber die würden
haben ja zum Glück trotzdem Wind davon
bekommen wie ist das passiert wie es das
öffentlich geworden das ist noch unklar
ist auch klar das Telegramm im kein
sicherer Messenger ist und das ist eben
der Vorteil auch von Telegramm Telegramm
von Sicherheitsbehörden in in aller Welt
tatsächlich auch entsprechend gehackt
werden das wird auch gemacht das wissen
viele nicht die diesen Dienst benutzen
und aus dem Grund gibt es da eben
Einfallstor und man muss immer
unterscheiden und so wird Terrorismus
Analyse gemacht indem man sich anschaut
welche Absicht haben bestimmte Akteure
und welche Fähigkeiten haben sie wir
haben hier eindeutig eben Absichten
scheinbar offensichtlich gewalttätig
vorzugehen und die Fähigkeiten also die
technischen Mittel und die taktischen
Fertigkeiten so etwas durchzuführen dass
es dann noch mal eine andere Geschichte
ob der die Fähigkeiten hier vorgelegen
haben ist eine andere Sache ist aber
keine Festnahmen heute morgen das deutet
z.b. darauf finde es eben tatsächlich
keine Schusswaffen
ansonsten wäre hier ganz anders
vorgegangen auch berichtet dass es auch
paketlieferungen an den Bundestag gab in
dem vermeintlich vergiftetes Fleisch
drin gewesen sein sollen das ist auch
öfter passiert also werdet sehen auf
jeden Fall eine zunehmende
Radikalisierung hier befürchten sie dass
das im Zuge der kommenden Impfpflicht
noch schlimmer wird ich gehe davon aus
also dass diese Impfpflicht ist für
viele die in diesem Foren sich in dem
Umfeld auch bewegen so ein bisschen rote
Linie und wenn es diese allgemeine
Impfpflicht gibt dann gibt es sicherlich
weitere die sozusagen die Absicht nur
wir Absicht und Fähigkeiten die also die
Absicht auch entwickeln dort vorzugehen
ob dann die Fähigkeiten da sind wird man
sehen aber sag mal so ist es definitiv
möglich dass es immer wieder kleinere
Verbände Gruppen gibt die dann sich dazu
entscheiden hier Gewalttaten zu Beginn
gegen z.b. Politiker die sie dafür für
symbolhaft halten malte roschinski
vielen Dank für die Anordnungen